in Westworld season 3 episode 6 Williams
in a mental hospital because Charlotte
had him committed in therapy there's
talk of hope and healing but William
gives an edgy nihilistic speech about
how humans are a virus and there's no
God and no meaning this is why William
loved Westworld
in the park there was meaning everything
was designed by the God like Ford and
when William was the powerful
gun-slinging man in black his speeches
were badass but now that he's a mental
patient he sounds more like a nutty old
man William faces the truth he admits
that he got confused and delusional in
Westworld and he killed his daughter
Emily
William feels he'd be better off dead
he's toyed with self-destruction since
last season but Williams put on a
special treatment called AR therapy
because this isn't a regular Hospital
this is one of the re-education
facilities where serac edits people who
don't fit into his system people like
John me and like Caleb we're told that
this treatment is used on veterans with
PTSD so now this facility tries to
change William Williams therapist gets
her inside profile his last episode
Dolores sent everyone the data revealing
how their watched and controlled the
therapist learns that since she's been
cheating on a partner and abusing drugs
she'll lose her family and her medical
license so she hangs herself Dolores is
daughter Lake causes real tragedy and
chaos we hear that half the staff at
this place have disappeared the staff
take a blood sample from William and
find unknown proteins and synthetic
markers in his blood and this is what
Charlotte injected William with in
Episode four
it's a tracker to find William's
location so Charlotte learns that
William and his facility are in Mexico
it's kind of weird that Charlotte sent
William to this hospital but now she
needs to track him to find where he is
last episode Martin laura's showed
Bernard this hospital and it seemed like
he already knew its location so it's
confusing but the point is that
Charlotte finds this facility in Mexico
May
it's the same place where serac edited
Jean me in that flashback and maybe it's
wet loris and Caleb are now flying
William has a drip installed the digital
drug device and to calm him the staff
give him a limbic tab called desert
oasis which is one of many drug flavors
listed on the inside website William
starts his AR therapy and it looks just
like Caleb's flashback so it seems like
he had the same treatment with the
combination of VR glasses and his drip
tripping him out William has visions of
his past he sees Craddock playing the
role of a nurse last season Craddock was
a Confederate oh hos to William killed
in an attempt at redemption then William
has a hallucinatory therapy sessions of
himself there's William as a child and
Jimmy Simpson William from season one
and corporate family man William and man
in black William present-day William
appears to have all his fingers even
though we just saw that he's actually
missing fingers that were blown off last
season that shows that this is all in
Williams head
he's just imagining himself with fingers
as like residual self-image like in the
matrix the therapy is run by James Delos
Williams father-in-law who Williams
seemed to admire and respect though he
also took James's company Delos and
trapped James in an immortality
experiment last season they all argue
about how and when William became such a
destructive fucked-up person William
thinks that maybe Westworld or his
childhood made him violent he says that
as a kid he had nothing except his books
he's been telling himself that since
season one we see a flashback of kid
William reading a book called sir Rowan
and the Lady of suit lon
which seems to be an invented book for
the show not a real book it mentions a
sir Logan like Williams brother-in-law
Logan and this lady looks a bit like
Dolores
so maybe William fits the role of sir
Owen Knight on some journey of
self-discovery
we see Williams dad being aggressive
with him and at first it seems like a
cliche story about William becoming bad
because his dad was mean
him but turns out kid William was the
main one he severely beat another kid
just for teasing him so the idea is that
William didn't become a monster he was
born a monster
it's like William said last season
there's a dark stain inside him that was
always there so William says he never
had a choice
James asks if William ever had free will
or if he was just a passenger
following his code the passenger was the
name of the season two finale which
concluded that humans are just
passengers with no free will and it's
only the hosts who can truly change and
grow so William says if you can't tell
does it matter which is what Angela told
him in season one maybe free will
doesn't matter
and maybe William's past doesn't matter
all these past Williams are dead and
gone only the present is real so William
kills all his past selves rejecting the
man he was he frees himself from the
prison of his own sins by destroying his
past serac says this episode that hosts
remember everything that humans can
forget by forgetting his past
William can become someone new he finds
new purpose and says he's the good guy
so what good will William do William
clearly doesn't care about humans need
hates himself and thinks Humanity is a
virus but he does feel guilty for
abusing Dolores so maybe he'll help
Dolores and the hosts take over the
world and maybe that was Dolores 'iz
plan maybe the reason why she sent
William here is so he would have this
revelation and come help her and if
Dolores manipulated William that might
suggest that he has no free will after
all either way this is probably not what
this a our therapy was meant to do Sarek
uses these facilities to make people
more predictable and controllable but
William's new sense of freedom and
purpose might cause more chaos Bernard
and Stubbs arrive and pull William out
of AR they say he was left in there too
long because the hospital was disrupted
by the Darla Lake
so maybe that's why Williams treatment
got so crazy Bernard is here because
Martin loris told him about this place
last episode and maybe they've got us
location from the Blood tracker but what
will Bernard and William do now how does
this all fit into the lorises plan it's
interesting that these shots don't show
Williams hands because if we ever see
William with all his fingers again that
might suggest that he's still inside the
AR treatment maybe what's happening
still isn't real Maeve awakes in a
simulation of the sublime the digital
heaven where Mavis daughter went last
season last time we saw may if she was
killed by Musashi Loras so serac plugged
Maeve's brain into this simulation while
he rebuilds her body Maeve wants to
reunite with her daughter in the sublime
but Dolores has the key to the sublime
so serac wants Maeve to kill Dolores and
get him the key to do this Maeve says
she needs help
so serac starts printing Hector and two
are the hosts to help Maeve serac
promises that if may have succeeds in
killing Dolores he'll let her go to the
sublime to heaven but if she fails
she'll go to a bad place which sounds
like hell serac is playing God and Maeve
seems to be obedient to him so far but
maybe she'll rebel and win her freedom
just like she did last season Maeve does
some combat training in war world
killing some Nazis for fun like neo and
Morpheus training in simulations and the
matrix previously Maeve's power to
control other hosts didn't work here but
it looks like serac has given back her
admin privileges it's kind of [ __ ] up
that Maeve kills these Nazis for fun
season one was all about how it's wrong
to kill hosts for fun sometimes
Westworld is more interested in being
badass than being morally consistent we
see a bar in war world called the tavern
Adela fawful which is italian for the
butterfly tavern Maeve saloon in West
world was called the Mariposa which is
Spanish for butterfly and in Shogun
world there was another Mariposa bar
this represents parallels and
consistencies across cultures it also
represents Lee Sizemore's lazy
because he copied and pasted storylines
when he wrote the Park narratives Lee
died last season but this simulator
digital lame exists in this simulated
war world he now knows that he's not
real so he drinks at the bar all day
which is not so different to what he did
when he was alive the simulation
shimmers for a moment because serac
moves Maeve's brain into the delos
building he starts printing bodies for
Maeve and for the other three hosts
who'll be her allies so maybe says
she'll be reunited with some old friends
we know one of these hosts is Hector and
another might be Clementine because this
ID number on the screen has appeared
before as clementines ID their third
host might be Hana yo the Shogun world
equivalent of Armistice her actress Tao
Okamoto confirmed that she had returned
this season maybe Hana yo will come up
against Musashi former ally Hector's
plugged into the simulation and Maeve
finally reunites with the real Hector
Maeve's gettin the old squad back
together and another host is plugged
into the simulation it turns out that
Martin Loras the Dolores copy
impersonating Martin Connells wasn't
completely destroyed in that explosion
last episode serac recovered the brain
and plugs it into this simulation so
that Maeve can talk with this copy of
Dolores Martin Loras appears here as
Dolores not as Martin because it seems
like this copies stayed true to Dolores
instead of diverging and changing into
his own person like Charlotte Loras does
so we get another dramatic conversation
between the two main rebel hosts in the
story may have says that Dolores has too
much power because she has the
encryption key to both the human data in
the forge and to all the hosts in the
sublime she's the gatekeeper to two
species
Dolores says she's using her power to
fight for a future for the hosts she's
out here protecting the data making new
hosts saving their species from
extinction
Maeve has only been fighting for her own
loved one her daughter
Mavis sacrificed heaps of people for the
sake of the one person she cares about
but of course Dolores says also
slaughtered heaps
of humans and hosts ultimately they've
both done terrible things but Dolores
said they had to the species is in a war
of survival which means they're not
heroes or villains they're just
survivors and sadly they seem doomed to
fight each other because since they have
different priorities they can't trust
each other with the power of the
encryption key will these two
protagonists ever make peace charlotte
tries to protect her family from chaos
since dolores released in sights Dada
everyone's realized that they're being
watched and controlled by algorithms so
all over the world people freaked out
there's rioting looting someone throws
their clothes out the window it's
anarchy but would this really happen
from a data leak in the real world there
have already been leaks revealing global
surveillance and systems of control it's
been reported that the Chinese
government in Xinjiang uses AI tech and
surveillance data to target and arrest
suspicious people there's a million
people imprisoned in reeducation camps
right now under this data surveillance
system and there's no mass chaos over
that but in West world San Fran gets
chaotic some kids paint an image of the
maze in season one the maze represented
the hosts journeys to consciousness and
freedom now it's the humans who have to
escape control and the maze that are
trapped in his insights system the
insight logo looks like a maze shaped
like a globe at Jake's house there's an
ENSO circle in the background a Buddhist
symbol which looks a lot like the
Rehoboam circle Rehoboam it's looking
chaotic right now because the world is
getting chaotic deviating from surak's
plan
Charlotte Loras has a touching moment
with Jake this Charlotte started out as
a copy of Dolores but the living
Charlotte's life has changed her and she
now genuinely cares for Charlotte's
family but first she's got to stop serac
from taking over the Della's company
because Dolores wants to use Delos as
technology to make more hosts the plan
is to vote to make Dilys private but
serac assassinates one of the board
members they don't have enough votes
so serac takes over the Delos company he
now owns West world Charlotte feels
defeated but Dolores tells Charlotte to
smuggle out the Delos host technology
anyway
Dolores says they'll build a new world
together
but at a time when Charlotte is scared
and needs support Dolores is not as
sympathetic and loving as Jake was so
Charlotte feels closer to a human family
than to Dolores and the hosts
Dolores says she and Charlotte
considered removing their painful
emotions but they decided to keep them
cuz what's the point of surviving if you
lose the feelings that make life
meaningful
Dolores learned this last season when
she removed Teddy's empathy and fear to
help him survive she realized that was a
mistake when Teddy committed suicide
serac rolls up and takes charge of the
Della's company his Rehoboam watch gets
more neat and ordered showing that the
world is getting back to his plan all
sirok wants from Delos is the encryption
key to get the human data from the forge
everything else he destroys he doesn't
care about the business of the West
world parks and he doesn't care about
the hosts right to survive all the hosts
who have known of the previous seasons
are burned in a robot genocide so before
serac deletes everything charlotte
downloads a backup of the hosts daughter
and she seems to upload it somewhere
safely charlotte stands by this statue
which is similar to this mirrored statue
in episode 3 the mirrored statue
represents Dolores and char Laura's
together identical and symmetrical but
this new statue stands alone it
represents how Charlotte is becoming a
separate person to Dolores and it's
rough texture might foreshadow that
she's about to be burned Ciroc calls a
meeting and Charlotte pointedly removes
a bracelet for no apparent reason
on the still watching podcast actress
Tessa Thompson revealed that this was
actually to fix a continuity error
because they shot some stuff out of
order and they forgot to have the
bracelet on in later scenes Ciroc
reveals that he knows that charlotte is
a host because the real Charlotte would
never have been so concerned about her
family
it's kind of ironic that the fake robot
Charlotte is a more attentive mother
than the real human Charlotte was that
said we did see the real human Charlotte
send an emotional message to her son so
maybe humans are more able to change
than serac realizes Charlotte tells
serac that she secured the host data but
Zurich laughs and says he was watching
her all along so it sounds like those
files didn't actually get through
Charlotte tries to shoot serac but he's
just a hologram he played her surak's
goons attack and Charlotte goes full
terminator to escape Charlotte wants to
make sure that maven allies can't come
after her so Charlotte destroys Hector's
pearl since the originals at Westworld
are destroyed this means that Hector is
permanently dead well this is West world
so someone might still make a simulation
or a copy from memory of him or
something but the point is that
Charlotte has murdered Maeve's lover and
now the freshly printed Maeve looks
determined to destroy her before
Charlotte can destroy Maeve and the
other allies as well she is attacked so
she finds a way to escape with the help
of a friendly robot she grabs Martin
lorises brain on the way out so maybe
he'll continue to be a character
Charlotte escapes and returns to a human
family she seems to be leaving Dolores
once and for all and embracing a life
with Jake and Nathan she promises to
keep them safe and then their car
explodes killing Charlotte's family one
theory was that Dolores might have blown
up this car because she wants to
separate Charlotte from a human family
and make it loyal to the hosts but Evan
Rachel Wood confirmed that serac blew up
the car apparently to kill Charlotte but
the guy who blows up the car doesn't
bother to check that Charlotte's dead
which is dumb because Ciroc just
recovered Martin after he seems to die
in an explosion and indeed Charlotte
survives too she crawls from the wreck
like Anakin in Star Wars burnt and
grieving at the loss of her loved ones
maybe he liked Anakin this will be the
origin of a darker
angrier Charlotte maybe she'll be more
loyal to the hosts now and want to take
down serac
revenge the hosts are often defined by
tragic cornerstone memories like Bernard
losing Charlie and Maeve losing her
daughter maybe Charlotte losing her
family will be her cornerstone memory
and she'll finally truly become her own
person making her own choices so this
episode decoherence is all about change
and divergence William rejects his past
to find a new path Maeve and Delores
deepen their divide Charlotte's identity
is burned away and she rises again to
take a new form West world has been
renewed for a fourth season
there are also upcoming seasons of His
Dark Materials the expanse Foundation
and the June movies which are the kinds
of series we'll cover after this season
of West world we'll also do more videos
on the Game of Thrones books author
George Martin says he's working to
finish the upcoming next book so now's a
good time to raid the series as well as
the main books there's the world book
the dunk and egg stories and fire and
blood which the upcoming prequel TV show
is based on you can get any of these on
audiobook for free right now by signing
up for a trial with audible members get
an audiobook each month and if you
cancel you keep the audiobooks you can
listen while you train in the matrix so
while you drink and complain sign up at
audible.com slash ASX thanks for
watching please like and subscribe
we're holding live streams right off to
each episode of Westworld season 3 at
10:30 p.m. Eastern Time Sundays patreon
supporters can watch the live streams
after their broadcast thanks to patrons
Stephanie Ramirez Shakib Majid Hugo King
xavier spain nico de makers laura
rodriguez and oscar Cheers
you